[Music]
in my own words modernization is about
basically get get on-premise get legacy
virtualized environments and getting
them to you in a way where you can
actually run them as containers where
you can operate them with less overhead
for what you know for basically
programmability upgrades patching and
how to run in a cloud environment in in
a more automatic way where you can start
once you are there leveraging cloud
products and cloud tools that we offer
so this is kind of our view of
modernization so I would say if you take
a a virtual machine as a starting point
and we get to an end point which would
be running on a container and having C
ICD pipeline instrumentation having
monitoring troubleshooting tools
real-time that will show you what your
application is doing with the rest of
the world how many customers are
touching it how many connections per
second
who this application is talking with
which other application interfaces with
what's the latency and so forth that's
one part and then another part is well
how do I upgrade my application how do i
patch it how do I move it how do I make
sure it scales and so once you are in
this environment you are modernized and
so this is what modernization means to
me and now what I'd like to cover is
basically to see why why we're doing it
why we're modernizing so interpret
enterprise ideas complex why is it
complex because you're in an environment
where you have multiple different
systems in your infrastructure you may
have virtualized environments you may
have bear meadow you may have legacy
middleware and and basically you'll end
up in an environment
you have a bunch of things to make work
and you need to make them evolve because
your tasks to evolve this system so your
initial tenth starting point is
complicated and that's what you have and
that's your environment and basically
you for your company in your environment
to be responsive and competitive it has
to quickly evolve if you have a new
application coming up a new service that
you want to offer to your customers you
have to quickly do it and and so on one
hand you're facing the environment that
exists and on the other hand there is a
need of more and more agility into your
environment faster and faster deployment
times for applications and so forth and
so we started being a place where we
need to do trade-offs and the trade-offs
are in three different types basically
one is about security and agility so you
want to be agile but at the same time
you want your application to be secure
enough and so you started think to how
to get more agile but at the same time
your security teams would want not want
you know this to be more impactful with
the data so you have to think about
these two how they coexist that's number
one number two is real reliability and
cost so you want to basically have an
infrastructure that is where cost is
less and less and so forth but at the
same time you want it reliable you don't
want to have failures you don't want to
have outages you want uptime and SL O's
you want to make sure that if you have
customers using your environment there
are in Asia in Europe in the u.s. that
based on who they are and where they are
they have a latency and application
response time that suits you know what
you want to provide to them and same for
internal applications so if you are
hosting your internal applications
somewhere on the cloud you want to make
sure that a it works and to that it
works well enough with the proper
performance right and the number three
is portability and consistency so how
can I move my application to a different
environment how can I go from my
on-premise to the cloud how can I go
back
from the clout in on-premise how can I
have multiple clouds coexist and at the
same time be agile if a new service
appears somewhere and I want my
application to benefit from it I'd like
to move it there and so that's the the
thinking of the trade-offs that we need
to do in order to basically modernize an
environment and basically you know what
we need to embrace is how do we new new
things how do we transform this IT
environment versus you know doing the
same thing somewhere else right so you
know what a media a CIO of a media
company found is that 90% of legacy apps
would not be optimized by moving to the
cloud but by just moving an application
doesn't mean that you start benefiting
from all what the cloud has to offer you
and if you don't modernize what happens
well you have underutilized resources
you have turnover
some people may go somewhere else losing
interest and so forth downtime you have
downtime as well because you're not more
modern you don't have a 24/7 reliability
you have to have maintenance windows you
have to take down time to upgrade and so
that's another part of not modernizing
and third well you may be locked in with
you know specific vendors and not have
the agility to move when you want to
move and there's more and more this need
to adapt yourself to the environment
because there's so many new ways to do
business and to do technical application
deployments and so many new software's
and ways of doing the same thing
somewhere else and in another ways you
want to be more you want to give
yourself the chances to succeed and this
is why we're so much thinking about
modernization and why we're spending
time on this product for modernizing and
so basically the fact that you will
modernize it's not that it's it's
basically an end of something and you
have to rebuild and figure out how to do
it it's basically a way
to find a different way to build your
environment in a modern modernized
infrastructure okay
and so the technologies for
modernization here I put the five key
ones that that I see micro-services what
does micro services means micro-services
means the flexibility to move at the
speed that your developers move okay
containers containers means repair
repetitive repeatability and scalability
you can run something of you can have an
application that's portable and that can
be repeated and moved to various places
in a faster way okay
orchestration what does orchestration
means it means that we have systems that
will automate and move these
applications where it makes sense when
it makes sense see ICD what is that that
means that you will be shipping code
hourly and you will be agile you won't
be on a quarterly basis for example the
development release you will just push
the code when it's when it's available
and when it's tested and these are kind
of the services and API management so in
you know automate your management with
basically having an API framework where
you will touch other applications and
you will have a tight integration
between different different parts of
your lifecycle different applications in
your in your life cycle right so these
are the technologies that are part of
this modernization journey it is a big
deal when we look at customer surveys
and and basically market surveys
migration and modernization are a big
deal what you see here is migrating
existing applications to the cloud
most people believing that right
evolving the application is also
important in top-of-mind so these are
really key aspects in terms of
modernizing infrastructure and
that's what people that's what we get
from from markets now the problem with
that is that it's actually complicated
it's hard it's a hard thing to do
everyone wants to modernize but how do
we do it and when we look at some more
more more data more statistics over 90%
of enterprises migration projects face
delays over budget right why is it why
is it so hard
number one the scale so you have
thousands of workloads for example in a
data center and you need to move that to
the cloud how do you do it
so you will start evaluating solutions
doing a scale of 1-10 20 workloads how
do you do this at scale how do you go
thousands of VMs how do you move a
physical data center to the cloud it's a
hard thing to do it involves planning
understanding the framework the
architecture the networking the security
bits and then being able to do that on
the cloud so it's actually an extension
of your environment multi-source well
there are are certain things that you
cannot move to the cloud therefore you
know legal reasons for practical reasons
there is a bunch of different reasons
where you will need to run still certain
application on your data center at a
physical at physical locations and they
should coexist with the ones that you
move and so therefore you know when you
move certain things away run him on the
cloud and they have to talk to your own
premise you need to make sure that where
they are again latency is is good enough
response time SLA z' and all these
things right
so that's multi-source QE well they are
the applications are complex multi-tier
applications if we look at databases if
we look at services that you run you
know typically they're developed by
someone and then oftentimes you know
that the application is running and it's
a complex application solving one of the
things in your environment in your
company but you don't know how
graded you don't know what it's doing
and and you still would like to migrate
it so you would like to have tools that
figure out what the application is and
then enable you to take that to the
cloud in a way that makes sense and to
still have it functional so we also have
that part of capability with what we
were looking at with anthos migrate and
the last part is the risk so we
oftentimes talk with about when we talk
migration we talk about moving you to
the cloud in migrating you but one
aspect that's not often talked about is
well what do you do if it doesn't work
you want to make sure you can actually
go back on premise and so the software
for migration that you look at you want
to have a seamless way of actually
moving to the cloud but also back on
premise and so you want a an environment
that gives you that flexibility and
gives you the same timeframe or the same
performance whether you go to the cloud
or whether you come back on premise at
any given time so this is our solution
when we look at modernization and how we
do it so what I will tell you now is
about our product enthis migrate that
gives you this modernization aspect for
your workloads and what we modernize is
that we take workloads running on bare
metal on virtual machines whether it's
on your on-premise or whether it's on a
different cloud and how do we take those
workloads Windows or Linux and we move
them over to GCP and when it's Linux
today we actually move them into
containers and so it's a one step
process to get you directly to the
container journey and to get you to run
on gke and that's really the value here
that the leap of technology we're taking
into modernizing your VM running
somewhere and then ending up as
this VM runs in a container on GK and
then you can leverage all the ecosystem
of the things that we talk about around
GK so this is our vision it's about
migrating and modernizing the VMS and
the way we will take you there is
basically it can be a one step process
or it can be a multi step process
depending on how ready you are and where
in your journey you are and what you see
here on this graph we start to read this
graph by the bottom left side which is
your starting point
you are either on-premise or another
cloud and you have a workload okay then
you can actually go directly and and
your journey is running on the top left
side as a container on GK you can do
that directly with entus migrate or we
can do it also in a two-step process
with Antos migrate so we can take you
first to run on for example on GC P so
we can get your VM to run as a VM on
Google Cloud and then modernize it or we
can modernize you directly so depending
on where you are in your journey you
don't have to wait for this right you
can start and we can meet you in your
journey of modernization where you are
here is our approach and and our
approaches is this - but possible phase
this is the journey of a migration and
I'm trying to show you here the life
cycle right so we start with a pre cell
first environment where when we have
conversations about migration we talk
about discovery and what discovery is is
to figure out what your environment is
what really is happening in your IT
environment what applications are
running what are the dependencies where
are they located what is their network
what are the security policies and so
forth
then comes the migration planning which
is still a more of a paper phase or
discovery phase which we start thinking
about
what are we going to migrate when and
how and then we go into our basically
step next step which is our migration
practice and what you see here is two
different trains that we can take the
top one that we run on GCE so the top
one is we take a VM running on premise
and then we go and run that as a
migration and we end up on GCE so that's
our lift and shift technology and at the
bottom one you see our type of doing
that with GK so similar processes but
it's just that we can adapt the journey
to where you are and this is why we this
is what we offer you with our software
with what CentOS migrated so I want to
go through the benefits of two things I
want to go over the VM to VM migration
and then I'll tell you about our VM 2gk
migration so the two different aspects
of our product what you see with our VM
to VM migration is that we actually want
to move you it's our lift and shift want
to move you to Google cloud with a fast
paced technology the way we achieve that
is we actually have a couple of key
benefits one is we have what we call
real-time streaming with real-time
streaming what we do is when we start
your migration journey see it as when
you're running a VM on premise we start
a VM on Google cloud on GCP so in about
five to ten minutes depending if it's
Windows or Linux we fire up the VM in
DCP the disk the data the storage of
your initial VM is basically streamed to
your destination VM on the cloud and
then we cache it and we transfer the
data in the background so what this
means for you is that you actually
within minutes know if you're migrated
workload is actually operational and you
don't have to wait for the whole
migration to finish to then test it
see if it's actually functioning so
within minutes you can test the
migration and we can migrate storage in
the background this allows us to
accelerate the migration and really to
make it to make it meaningful to you in
a sense that you actually can understand
if you're your destination result will
actually work with what you want it to
be we don't need to install agents on
your VMs it's an agentless design we can
test before migration and we can roll
back
so with these benefits where you see on
the chart is you can actually over time
migrate a lot more at scale vm's and
this is real customer data you can
migrate at scale thousands and thousands
of VMs in with our automated process
right and scale of operations another
thing to show you here is the VMS so say
we take a two-week migration journey
which is fairly typical for production
migrations first week is discovery
second week is the implementation you
can actually see that in our second week
the migration completes very the VM
starts running right away and then the
data being transferred in the background
we're actually getting you up and
running very quickly in that second
second phase when it's the real
migration and that's with the technology
that we have behind anthos migrate now
let's talk about the second point so I
told you about VM to VM migration now
it's about VM to containers well many
workloads so you're developing
applications and your new applications
are say running on GK you're running as
containers but now you also have legacy
workloads and for those you don't want
to rewrite them but if you can move them
to the cloud and on GK then you can
instrument them and interface them with
the modern micro services that you're
building and take advantage of the same
benefits of GK where you have we managed
the kernel for you you
have access to our CI CD pipeline where
you can use other services such as sto
and services mesh and interact with your
micro service applications so we take
those legacy apps where rewrite is not
an option and we have it to run for you
in a container on GCP why wouldn't you
just do a lift and shift well if you
were just doing lift and shift and just
moving it as a VM you would get some
benefits but not as much as if you run
as a container especially when you are
looking at you know especially because
of the modernization reasons that we
were talking about and then finally we
don't see the migration as a binary
problem right so even we have customers
that understand that containers gke and
so forth is interesting although they
don't see all the benefits right away we
can meet you where you are in your
migration journey and we can take you to
that step forward to GK's so it's it's a
further toolbox that you have for your
app and another point here is well why
do we do this a big reason why this
comes back is customers love GK GK is
today a leading container serve managed
service that is that a lot of our
customers just want to be on because of
all the other benefits we have once you
are on GK and legacy apps once they're
there again they're on boarded you start
to see the benefit of it so now think
about if you had to move to containers
your own apps yourself and rewrite them
or rebuild them and you have to do that
at scale it's probably not something
that's going to be either happening or
that's going to be really appealing for
you to do so they may end up saying so
what we do with our capability of
running these legacy workloads
middleware databases and so forth we
enable you to meet us in the
jurnee very quickly and we run this
container same as our VMs to VM
migration about five minutes or so
you're up and running with the data what
you saw today at our keynote is was a
migration of an online boutique app that
we would that would start a run on
premise and then goes to the cloud it
takes about a minute or so to move that
app and with our streaming technology so
I have another example which is fairly
similar
this is about an s AP database for
example where we do a migration and what
you see with that migration is the time
it takes to running the cloud and the
time it takes to complete so this was
for 36 servers with 3.25 terabyte of
data the full migration was done in 36
hours so completely complete end-to-end
right so that's the the landscape you
know that's that's what it takes with
doing the live data migration 36 hours
if you look at using anthos migrate
you're up and running in the cloud
already in 3 hours and that's a real
production a CP large database ok a
little bit about our process these are
this is my last my last slide this is
just so you understand what happens
the modernization starts from kubernetes
itself from gke we actually decide to
start the migration with a llamó file
then our initial point starting point is
a data center where you have virtual
machines running on there's a hypervisor
stacks or storage this is the middle
picture here so GK start the
modernization process with a llamo and
basically our anthos microsoft word
moves those two VMs into two new
containers on GK as you can see on your
right hand side here and when they're on
GK
you basically can leverage all the
ecosystem around around that
okay so that's that's kind of the whole
idea the whole idea here is we start
migrating from kubernetes itself and
then we end up with these VMs running in
specific clusters as stateful sets and
up and running on on kubernetes so once
you're there everything that's
automation pipeline modern tools
orchestration API management services
about security mash these Chios and so
forth are things you can leverage right
away last slide what can you what can we
migrate right so here is here is the
example of our workloads it's mainly
going to be tomcat web server web apps
multi tier apps it's going to be
WebSphere WebLogic it's going to be
databases and basically we support the
operating systems that you see which are
Linux Red Hat and scent OS Suzy and
Ubuntu okay so that's currently what we
support in in our environments we are
looking to do Windows and we'll talk
about that later on but that's what we
support currently with our with our
product ok so key benefits at a glance
once you are on kubernetes here are the
things that you can you can benefit from
first one is you can run your stateful
app in G k2 you have access to the
security aspects of GK that we offer 3
you're moving fast in a standard
containerized way and then we offer you
an easier to rebuild app to run in a
modern environment manageability OS
patching and automated pipeline so this
is more of a summary key benefits just
to get everyone on board with what we're
bringing on
with kubernetes so with that we have
another about 20 minutes or so what I'd
like to do next is to actually talk to
you about our real-world case studies
and in a in a second I will call up our
actually what I call our customers to
come up on stage what I wanted you to
see is some examples of our applications
that we can migrate and modernize CRM
application for example WebLogic JBoss
ASAP all these are example of things
that we can migrate with 2gk so with
that I would like to call our three
customers on stage we have Michael
Walker and Luke that will join us and so
we can have a little panel for the
remaining of the time while they get set
up what I'd like to to tell everyone we
also have a Dory that's open so if you
have questions now that you'd like to
ask you know we can then follow up as
questionnaire after that so don't
hesitate to use the Dory and and now
we'll do we'll go ahead and talk about
the panel so first thank you for joining
me thank you Michael Walker and Luke
first thing I'd like to do is is to ask
you about tell me about your companies
so tell me about what you're doing and
how that pertains to cloud so Michael if
you like to start maybe and tell us yeah
sure Atos and who you are and introduce
your company sure so my name is Michael
Cole Garmin cloud engineering for Atos
we're a global manage service provider
and we help our customers one one
existing workloads and systems but also
we help migrate them to cloud and a lot
of that is through whether it be fully
transformed in the cloud running full
micro services containers of them or
some of it is lift and shift and we do
it on a variety of platforms including
the legacy so for us a lot of legacy
support where we integrate cloud modern
technologies with legacy through things
like cloud service broker sto and the
some of the transformation capabilities
from Villa Strada thank you Michael
okay how about you yeah I'm Walker
Miller I'm from Cardinal Health we are a
global healthcare pharmaceutical and
medical supplies manufacturer and
distributor we have been in the process
over the last couple years of doing a
massive migration from on-premise to
cloud using I get well fellow strata at
the time is what it was we are just
about finished we'll be done in July
with most of our production instances so
and we've been experimenting a bit with
this new product as well look I'm Luke
Webb I'm on the cloud enablement team
with Tyson Foods food company in about
40 billion dollars in sales last year
across four main be used which are beef
poultry pork and prepared foods so we
operate you know across multiple states
and multiple countries and our IT
workforce is also spread you know across
those locations we started a cloud
migration and a digital transformation
about 18 months ago and so we've been
doing a lot of discovery a lot of
testing you know a lot of a lot of
deciding on how we want to do things so
we know how we want to do things and
just wanna figure out how to get there
right to that end state so we have a
pretty aggressive cloud migration
strategy
the Lestrade is going to be part of that
let's talk about a little bit about
scale and I think Walker you're you're
one of our lead examples tell us about
scale in terms of how large or you know
where are you in terms of that journey
of migrating you've experienced our
product with you know migrating certain
workloads and then moving you know a
higher amount how is that being how is
that process been for you and do you
foresee a similar type of activity for
potentially containers as you look at
your modernization journey are you also
thinking maybe scale or are you thinking
how do you see that to fit and of the
your your model for your company yeah
well I think when we're done we'll have
migrated around 4,000 servers we're
probably I mean we're probably 75 80
percent done with that we just got
production knock off probably getting
closer to 85 90 percent here so yeah I
mean we've been doing it over couple
years you know spent a lot of time doing
discovery and analysis which allowed us
to be successful as far as the container
I'm not really sure yet what that's
going to look like I think that's kind
of new to us we've been doing it
internally with a few apps just kind of
building cloud native just to get an
idea where we'll be going live with our
first production kubernetes app in May
so we're still kind of early adopters in
there as well for us it's and I don't
know what the the the end games gonna
look like for that quite yet but I have
a feeling an inkling that containers are
going to be a pretty integral part of
that for all of our technology staff
Michael we we talked about a little bit
earlier you're telling me about you know
migrations in general and containers do
you foresee this technology that's it's
something that you like to take for
modernizing a lot of your customer
breadth or activities with containers
how do you see that compare how do you
see our new technology with containers
to play a role for Atos compared to say
you know traditional lift and shift or
or moving to the cloud activities for
for basically your company yeah so we've
built a platform in partnership with
Google that we call the orchestrated
hybrid cloud it's based on kubernetes
and it's a container based platform for
micro service applications micro service
based applications um one of the things
we need to do is take legacy
applications at scale and move them to
containers essentially break down the
dependencies that they had on operating
systems VMware and some of the other
proprietary technologies that we had so
in order to facilitate that we needed a
technology that allowed us to undo that
separation but then also create what I
would say are smaller more segmented
apps micro services onto a modern
platform that we could then integrate
and then orchestrate whether they'd be
on Prem because we have a requirement
some of our customers still want
infrastructure on Prem like it or not
they've got regulatory requirements
things of that nature but then also
provide the way to scale it and
integrate it with public cloud offerings
that make more sense for them so for us
containerization is critical to
transform customers and we have
customers today that are building cloud
native applications that way and also
want to take some of the what they would
refer to as their low-hanging fruit tier
3 and tier 4 apps that really don't make
sense to keep on Prem anymore but they
could just move to the cloud and do that
in a container based approach and take
it take full advantage of what Google
has to offer there Luke how about you so
for Tyson Foods how do you how do you
see that model to play what type of
applications potentially do you see for
for migration in general I would say to
the cloud what are the top of minds and
what are you thinking in terms of
containers and
you know migrations to that in terms of
type of workloads that you're looking at
yeah so I mean everything in our data
center is is on the block for migration
to the cloud you know and containers are
definitely part of our our strategy
anything cloud native that we're
building we're definitely pushing
development teams to use kubernetes
micro-services cloud functions those
kinds of technologies but as far as
migrating what we have in our data
centers today I we're not sure what all
those things fit into kubernetes right
so we have we have a lot of ERP systems
that maybe don't fit that model but we
do have some you know web hosted
applications that definitely would fit
in there and we have a lot of a lot of
Windows VMs which aren't on the beta
release of this software but are on the
roadmap so we're interested to see you
know what comes in that space as far as
Windows bm2 kubernetes migrant windows
in terms of you know in terms of I would
say challenges what do you gentlemen see
as potentially current challenges for
migration is it you know what is it for
you that's the biggest challenge I would
say when you or one of the biggest
challenge when you look at migrations
whether the blockers for you today for
your environment so I can give you two
that we struggle with so embedded
security inside of Apps okay something
that even when we do the discoveries and
things like that we don't typically find
someone did role based access should go
back and time the products like Mac
Tegrity and stuff like that did roll
provision and dynamically for the user
so how that happens in the public cloud
is going to be very different when we do
that migration because that service is
no longer there so we're gonna have to
do something to recreate it the second
area that we get a little hung up on is
the ability to deal with or rollback
because the batch processes we have to
support or downstream dependencies
sometimes when we migrate an application
or we
the same way that that app got triggered
previously in its previous state it's no
longer the same way we would want to do
in the future because the legacy systems
don't understand event based programming
and things of that nature that we do for
the new world so we have to look at how
do we deal with keeping some of those
events or externalizing those events to
keep some of the systems that don't come
over and sync so security and embedded
types of batch processes and legacy type
integration approaches are some of the
inhibitors or blockers we see where
we're migrating the containers yeah I
would say with the UM with the migration
as a whole I mean our biggest problem
was just knowing what talks to what so
discovery was our biggest challenge it's
just because of the nature of on-prem
and segregation of duties
you had application teams that that they
really don't fully understand how their
applications work with other things so
going through and digging through all
the data we had to in order to figure
out that was was probably the biggest
challenge we had clearly really staff
yeah as far as moving something to to
kubernetes the technology doesn't scare
me at all their technology is pretty
sound I haven't I mean a women playing
with um traditional web store
application server in kubernetes and
even just building it natively it works
well that's that's not really issue if
you're running on least on Linux you're
gonna run in the container pretty well
one of the reasons we like kubernetes
over other options is that it allows you
to run in that way - you don't
necessarily have to make it cloud native
or you don't have to be a micro service
you can be a traditional VMs or so I
think the biggest challenge for us is
gonna be vendors and just dealing with
them and making sure they're willing to
support us running into a container
environment I liken it of the move from
physical to VMs years ago which I had
the luxury of being around for and you
know when you went to a lot of vendors
and said hey we want to run this on in a
virtualized environment they just said
no we're not going to support it and
eventually that that turn happened I
feel like that turn will happen here as
well
I would say probably resource
constraints have been higher our biggest
challenge so far you know ever since we
started our cloud journey we've been on
a big project we had acquired another
company that had their entire IT
infrastructure their own ERP system so
we've been combining those two you were
also we were founded in 1935 so we're
definitely a born analog company we have
a lot of old processes that got pushed
into an ERP system well we we modified
our EIP ERP system is a highly
customized system so part of this
journey is just a digital transformation
to use SAS software like SAS software
and not modify it unless there's some
sort of you know distinguishing feature
of Tison operations so really a lot of
resources have been tied up in that
effort so resources and then skill set
when the resources are tied up elsewhere
they can't develop the cloud skills that
they need to get onto this new platform
for our next generation of applications
so a tool like VM to gke is definitely
very attractive if you can get a push
button move into a new more modern
environment than you don't have to take
all that time from your developers and
your IT team to get them onto that new
platform for social security Security's
one aspect another aspect is basically
talking about you know you mention about
support for applications from vendors
when you go to the cloud and how are you
supported and another one is is
obviously what you mentioned as well
with you know the various things that
you have to manage and then on bore them
to the cloud we see what we seem to see
is a few things so one is you know we
think I think that the cons where you
brought up Walker about the support for
you know certain supports on containers
I think this is more of a time
you know a time constraint that's going
to ease up because I think it's
something that we see that everyone
wants everyone wants to move to
containers so I think we start to see
various companies more open on the
support model so I think that's you know
that's more on the I would say support
and it's very important for production
but I think we'll get there in terms of
security and and what we do for you know
once your containers I think that what
we're now working on on East Hill with
the service mesh is going to be really
compelling in terms of adding more
security and then with Nomos and
identity to be able to basically have a
user so if you are on the Active
Directory windows type of environment
now you can actually if you take our n
post migrated software now we can
actually directly map to you know user
you know users that are in 80's to be
moved to containers to gke with the law
you know the user that I am settings of
GCP so I think the security aspect is
definitely key because we want to make
sure we conserve that but that's a
really interesting problem that we're
looking to solve and then you know you
mentioned Luke I think also Windows and
Windows containers so Windows is a big
thing especially for legacy applications
this comes often times well I'd love to
go to gke but I have Windows so what do
I do with Windows we're actually working
on on the windows part this is something
you will see later on it's on our
roadmap we started now with Windows and
containers so this is we're starting to
have alpha and early access type of
things so I think the Windows part is
something that you know we're definitely
aware on and working on but in terms of
getting into containers
you know our software really has the
value of taking your VM and booting it
up as a stateful set on GK so we're not
yet at a stage where we break an
application into micro services but the
first step of what we're doing is we
take your legacy VM
then we get that to boot up and run in a
container and then it can start
interface with other things and at the
same time once it's on containers you
actually get more scale so you could
actually get a lot more workloads to run
on the GK cluster versus say a VN
cluster so these were kind of of things
where we are what what I wanted to ask
you guys is maybe what would be a one
top-of-mind things that you will you
would like to see in the product or what
are the things that you're thinking of
you know once you're on containers what
would you like to see that may be
missing or that is top of mind for you
as a next step to maybe get you more
towards why I think you just touched on
it for us so getting a VM or a legacy
app up into containers is great but it
doesn't break it down into
micro-services type architecture for you
so just like Walker mentioned that the
discovery is the hardest part so
anything that a tool could do to help
you discover how an application talks to
other applications and what databases
that require it it is required of those
kind of things would really be helpful
the full integration with this CEO is
going to be nice you know in the idea of
discovery if we had had a service match
like SEO in place or any service
mentioned place for that matter that
would have made that a lot easier
because we would have been able to see
those interactions a lot better than we
do now so servers mesh is kind of high
on our list for just kind of all of our
workloads and I would like those to see
given that we spend a lot of times
integrating with legacy systems with our
customers understanding how we can
provide the mapping back to the legacy
within it as part of the discovery
process to keep those two worlds in sync
as we progress them forward so yeah
moving basically integration with CSM
how to move these apps and and and how
do we do micro services so the micro
services part is something that we're
thinking to do as our you know our
you've seen our ideas and that's
something hard to do is now once you are
on the container
and you run as a stateful set well you'd
like that to become microservices so how
do we break that monolith application
that's stateful to get you to a
stateless server less completely you
know autonomous type of applications so
that's also something that it's part of
what we're we're thinking about in terms
of solving but now that we're you know
we're looking at basically taking you on
GK and and moving forward with us I'm
personally very exciting to collaborate
with you guys on this and and for you to
be are our partners you know on the
journey as we started you know all these
testing and and product so will will
continue basically that and I terrain on
it so that's that's really what you know
that that makes sense you know it's
taking VMs getting getting people in
containers scaling it out at big scale
thousands and thousands of workloads and
then giving you the flexibility of of
the cloud
[Music]